well your husband's using his phone to
record everything tonight he was
recording us on our platform it cut to
him in the audience he was recording
your speech that's sweet yeah he's a
sweetie he's a sweetheart and and he he
he believed in this moment he he he just
I think maybe he manifested it YouTube
managed to live a normal life raise your
children yet still you are Angela
Bassett what does that mean to you how
have you navigated for this long so well
you know what we we are always just who
we were at six seven eight high school
that sort of thing you know raised by
mama who didn't take no mess you know
who you know made sure that you showed
up with Excellence she didn't take you
know we say no tea for the FIFA
right don't catch it right are you gonna
you know show up and and give your all
so I've just always you know lived my
life that way and I have that
expectation of myself and I have it of
them and I try to like ease up a little
bit on them because they can be like a
little tough and but I know they have
their own Journey also where do you keep
these initially it will go in the
kitchen hopefully it will be just a
little to the kids right you know and
then after about a week you know we'll
move it over to the other countertop
foreign